qu'alexi poulain un cofondateur du monde
moderne bonsoir alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
une période transitoire donc jusqu'à
l'automne durant laquelle des
restrictions viens de le dire resteront
possibles
le coc vide aldo large le comité a le
dos large
et c'est extrêmement inquiétant je crois
que aujourd'hui on peut être vraiment
inquiets pour nos libertés parce que
c'est trop facile de faire croire que
finalement on des confirme qu'il faut
retourner travailler que la vie reprend
qu'on ne fait pas de test parce que le
virus circule peu quelle est la logique
olivier ferrand dit que finalement on ne
fera pas 500 milles taisent parce que le
virus circule peu et puis de l'autre
côté la logique répressive celle qui
restreint toujours plus liberté se met
en place en france dans cette grande
démocratie dans cette grande république
eh bien voilà ce qu'il se passe on est
en train d'avoir un coup d'état déguisé
parce que ces lois là ces lois
scélérates qui sont les lois d'exception
elles s'inscrivent dans la loi et dans
le long terme c'était le cas pour le
terrorisme
et ça va être le cas avec ce virus là où
ça pouvait être entendue avec le
terrorisme parce qu'il y avait une
menace réelle avec les kalachnikovs avec
des gens qui s'organisait avec d'autres
gens c'est autre chose
le virus il est invisible on ne sait pas
quand est-ce qu'il va revenir on ne sait
rien donc on pourrait tout à fait
envisager que cet état de fait soit
reconduit éternellement et que
finalement nos libertés soient sacrifiés
sur l'autel de la sécurité à chaque fois
que l'on perd en sécurité que l'on gagne
en sécurité par dont on peut perdre en
liberté il n'y a pas de y'a pas de
raison réelle à part celle d'éviter des
manifestations d'éviter en fait de la
contestation dans la rue de contrôler
davantage les populations stop qu'ovide
le montre encore cette application est
un scandale
elle partage les adresses ip des gens
qui ont téléchargé cette application il
y à là
l'algorithme de google enfin tout tout
tout est bidon dans cette application on
voudrait continuer en fait de fliquer
les populations veut faire en sorte que
les gens soient contrôlés c'est
insupportable
on est le pays des libertés on l'était
du moins je crois que les français sont
conscients de ce qui se passe j'espère
il est temps de d'arrêter la dérive
autoritaire qui est en place depuis
l'élection des malades macro alors la
rapporteuse un mari hugh est venue du
côté de la république en marche
essaye d'apporter une explication à cela
dit le droit commun n'est pas suffisant
pour faire face aux dimensions
extraordinaires de cette crise qui
souligne la nécessité de pouvoir réagir
très rapidement face aux clusters est ce
que ça nous semble un petit peu audible
quand même alexis poulain non c'est un
prétexte évidemment on peut réagir
regardez comme ils ont réagi rapidement
ils ont demandé au restaurant de fermer
en 4h01 discours d'edouard philippe
c'était un samedi après midi et le
samedi soir il fallait fermer les le
pays réagit extrêmement rapidement les
lois sont faites pour que le pays régis
rapidement ces lois d'exception sont là
pour restreindre les libertés et rien
d'autre elles sont là pour censurer et
rien d'autre elles sont la peau parce
que le pouvoir aujourd'hui a peur de la
contestation dans la rue
mais regardez les policiers sont dans la
rue les soignants sont dans la rue les
roulants sont dans la rue tout le monde
veut retourner dans la rue parce que il
y a un vrai problème en france et il est
à la tête du pays
c'est tout c'est qu'aujourd'hui les gens
n'en peuvent plus des politiques des
malaises macro et lui continue dans ce
déni de réel dans cette volonté de dire
j'étais lui donc je fais ce que je veux
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça oui la
menace du virus est réelle mais c'est
pas avec des lois anti libertaire et des
lois qui vont nous priver de liberté
qu'on va lutter contre ce virus
loin de là bien au contraire il semble y
avoir des garde-fous quand même dans
notre démocratie a notamment exemple le
conseil d'état qui a tranché sur les
grèves les manifestations
ça veut dire tout de même qu'on a encore
une démocratie en pleine santé selon
vous où vous guerrier qu'elle est
vraiment
j'ai aujourd'hui non la démocratie est
totalement en danger regardez la volonté
de contrôle total des populations
que ce soit avec les drones et là encore
le conseil d'état est rentré dans la
danse en dix ans ça suffit les drones cc
attentatoires aux libertés individuelles
que ce soit avec le contrôle avec stop
qu'ovide que ce soit l'algorithme enfin
tout est fait aujourd'hui pour contrôler
davantage les populations
c'est inacceptable la liberté
elle est assortie bien sûr de droit et
de devoir de responsabilité
aujourd'hui on a un pouvoir qu'il ne
fait pas confiance à son peuple et c'est
bien tout le problème est un peuple qui
ne fait pas du tout confiance au pouvoir
et donc cette défiance qui n'est kiné
qui n'est pas saine fait qu'on arrive
sur cette situation qui est tout à fait
autoritaire dans l'es7 et que demain
demain comme aujourd'hui ça moi je suis
très inquiet parce que les voix qui
luttent qui disent qu'aujourd'hui le
danger est réel sont peu nombreuses on a
l'impression que tout ça se fait dans un
acceptation totale de violence
j'appelle les manades lafon le président
de la violence pour une raison c'est que
c'est inacceptable que trente
manifestants aient perdu un oeil
c'est inacceptable que des gens aient
perdu des mains dans les manifestations
c'est inacceptable qu'on ait vu autant
de violence parce que des gens
manifester pour ne pas perdre de pouvoir
d'achat pour ne pas être dégradés ne pas
perdre simplement ce qu'ils pensaient
être la république c'est à dire une
certaine liberté une certaine égalité
une certaine fraternité tout ce qui est
mis en place aujourd'hui à l'encontre de
cette devise républicaine
il est temps de réagir et non pas avec
la violence je suis anti anti anti
violence mais avec simplement la raison
soyons raisonnables et poule c laude
était temps de réagir l'élection
présidentielle n'est plus si loin on
sait à quel point le temps passe vite
vous pensez que le type d'erreur dont
vous parlez en tout cas vous parlez
d'une voilà vous êtes inquiet pour la
démocratie est ce que cela va se payer
dans les urnes pour emmanuel mac sont
selon vous oui mais c'est anecdotique
parce que ça va au delà des urnes je
crois que c'est une philosophie ces
tickets de caisse que qu'est ce que ce
pays on ne peut pas croire que parce
qu'on élit à un produit marketing parce
que le maquereau n'est rien d'autre que
ça enfin cesser et voilà il pendant cinq
ans il peut faire ce qu'il veut
et mettre le pays à feu et à sang c'est
inacceptable c'est pas ça la démocratie
je crois d'ailleurs que le rique ne le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne porté
par les gilets jaunes est là pour dire
combien c'est important justement que ce
pays reprenne ses esprits et se rendre
compte que la démocratie est attaqué par
tous mais c'est inacceptable ce qu'il se
passe
et justement c'est un déni démocratique
c'est à dire que c'est pas parce qu'on
est élu une fois que l'on peut faire ce
qu'on veut pendant cinq ans et les
contre-pouvoirs dans ce pays et la vème
république est fautive sont beaucoup
trop faibles les commission denquête de
alimentaire via les gens se disent que
finalement ces commissions là ne vont
pas aller juste vous regardez la sphère
des nanas les commission denquête même
du sénat qui ont fait un boulot
exceptionnel les ducaux vie d'un
aujourd'hui voulu habiller une femme de
confiance à cette commission d' enquête
sur la gestion de l'actif
mais elle fera ce qu'il peut avec les
pouvoirs qui lui sont conférés
et malheureusement on sait très bien que
ça n'ira pas très loin puisque si la
commission denquête avait un vrai
pouvoir
aujourd'hui on aurait une justice sur la
sphère benalla on aurait trouvé
retrouvez les cov on aurait ouvert les
coffres cette affaire d'état aurait lui
aurait été ouvert le grand tour on voit
bien qu'il ya une limite dans tout et
donc heureusement qu'on a le défenseur
des droits heureusement qu'on a le
conseil d'état heureusement que mémé
vous rendez compte on demande à quoi on
en est réduit c'est à dire que passe par
le choix d'un seul il faut autant de
d'énergie pour pouvoir protéger les
libertés de tous ça s'appelle pas pour
moi la république ni la démocratie
merci beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous